you can borrow an idea but you cannot
borrow the conviction that is what I
very quickly learned starting my very
first three streams of income 12 streams
later I finally managed to figure out
what works and what doesn't for me
personally as an architect so today I'm
going to share exactly that with you
what's going on guys my name is David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today we're not
going to fluff around we're going to
dive straight in to the content first of
all let's start with a failed stream of
income the very first business I started
was when I was 20. I decided to launch a
watch company that was based around
architectural principles I took
everything that I learned from
University and applied it to watch
manufacturing as good of an idea as this
was what I quickly Learned was the fact
that it was one extremely time consuming
to required an absurd amount of capital
to actually start which genuinely I did
not have as a university student but
three I invested my whole life savings
into it so it had to work for me which
is why I tried so hard to make it work
eventually that company ran for five
years and on paper it was profitable and
it was successful yes but in reality
what it was is a huge time and energy
waster I spent every living waking
moment on that business and it did not
generate enough income to be able to
actually justify and scale that business
further so I had to take a step back and
go this isn't the right idea let's move
on and start something else because I
did put all that time and energy into
starting that first company I learned a
lot of new skills which were
transferable to my second business I
started offering architectural services
in website design and website packages
this quickly took off I ended up having
lots of website clients that I spent all
of my free time developing their
websites for them on Wix I didn't charge
a lot because it was through Wix and in
my head I was just doing basically what
somebody else could do for them for
about the same price I was just being a
convenient service again I quickly
learned that my time versus the value
that I was being provided in this
business wasn't working out I was
spending weeks and weeks and weeks
developing one website for about two
thousand dollars so the third company I
started and again all three of these
were huge flops in the grand scheme of
things was a photography and videography
company as an architect I knew
architecture I had a Keen Eye for design
and I had an excellent eye for
photography so I offered my
architectural services for Real Estate
photography and real estate videography
again this did really really well up
front because I wasn't charging enough I
was undercutting the competition to be
able to get my foot in the door now
let's break down the nine streams of
income that are currently still
successful for me today first of all the
most obvious elephant in the room
YouTube so I believe I started this
YouTube channel about three or four
years ago and I've been posting a video
every single Monday for that entire
period of time it was a huge time
commitment it still is a huge time
commitment but it is now starting to
return five figures per year just off
the AdSense Revenue the best thing about
YouTube is that it goes hand in hand
with brand collaborations you don't
actually get too many brand
collaboration offers when you start out
and technically I'm still starting out
as of making this video I'm only at
about 32 000 subscribers so I'd
appreciate it if you smash that
subscribe button to make the number go
higher but what the reality is you don't
get those brand deals until you're
somewhere along the journey potentially
years and years in however at this point
in time I am starting to attract the
right Brands to work with I'm rejecting
all of the spam brands that just want
you to promote anything all the rubbish
in between and I'm only focusing on the
good value Brands so just like YouTube
being able to supplement five figures
per year these brand deals are now also
bringing in an additional five figures
per year what I also noticed is as the
subscribers grow so does the actual
community so a long time ago as I
started this journey I created a Discord
group for all Architects architecture
students and anybody in between to join
chat and collaborate completely free the
link is down below if you want to join
it but what this community quickly
provided me with was the ability to
provide my expertise to them as they
learn and as they evolve in their career
which then ended up resulting in my next
stream of passive income and that was
digital downloads on the architectural
space in my website I have a series of
digital downloads and I used to have
many many more in the past I took them
down redeveloped them and focused on the
key ones that were of interest to
everybody in the architecture Community
these digital downloads took me a very
long time to create but now that they're
created they're up on the website
they're available to download and it
doesn't take any more of my time so
after about six months this slowly
started to actually become profitable
and now after a year it is very
profitable and I'm very happy that I
started the digital download space on
the website as of about a week ago I
also started in the physical product
realm in the e-commerce store so now I'm
able to offer physical tangible products
that people are able to pay for and get
something in return rather than a
digital asset that they may not find
Value in again these physical products
took a very long time to develop they
took a lot of thought care creation and
testing sampling over and over again
until we got them perfectly right but
eventually we were able to put them all
together and put them online for
everybody to enjoy like I said it's only
been a week but the tree is starting to
bear fruit already so I am very positive
that this stream of income will also
become very fruitful I will make a side
note here as to why this e-commerce
store is succeeding versus why my
original store completely failed so now
that I've been on YouTube I've developed
an audience I've developed a community
I've developed a relationship with
people that know and trust me before I
was just some random University student
trying to sell some random watches that
nobody had ever heard of now I'm
offering something of value to people
something that is making their life
truly better and easier versus something
that added no value to anybody's life
now the next stream of income is
actually once again derived off YouTube
YouTube is quite a large tree with many
branches but this is the last one for me
and that is patreon so patreon generates
very little it's about 10 20 30 a month
it is not a lot but it is just another
little bit that adds to the overall
total now the next two have absolutely
nothing to do with architecture but they
are related to the entrepreneurial drive
and how my brain has developed over the
last 10 years trying to build all of
these different businesses as an 18 year
old I started investing in the share
market very very young and very early I
had no idea what I was doing I lost a
lot of money at the start and I wouldn't
recommend anybody just dive on head
first however I did also make a little
bit of money at the start which enticed
me to stay in the market stick it out
keep pushing keep learning new things
and that's exactly what I did 10 years
on I have developed a very good passive
stream of income dividend portfolio so
the dividend started at a couple hundred
dollars then they went up to a couple
thousand dollars and so on eventually
the dividend stream is a very good
passive stream of income but it does
take Capital at the start to be able to
generate something in return if you
think about it most Dividends are only
about five percent of what you put in
per year so if you put in a thousand
dollars you're only going to get fifty
dollars back you can't live off fifty
dollars you need a lot more to get a lot
more out in line with these dividends I
also do a little bit of Swing trading
that allows me to supplement those
dividends so I'll buy a share that I
know is a good dividend at paying share
but then at the same time it may go up
quite a lot and I'll be happy to sell it
and find something else for a better
price it's very simple buy load sell
High the tactic doesn't always work
hence why it is predominantly a dividend
portfolio and the swing trades just come
by basically luck the last two are very
obvious as an architect and anybody in
the architecture profession most of the
time you're going to have your own job
you're going to be actually working for
somebody or for yourself so that means
you're going to have a salary as the
base Foundation of your income for me
personally at the moment it is about a
60 40 split with a salary at 60 and this
side incomes at 40. the side incomes
have been growing very rapidly over the
past couple of years and hopefully it
will be able to destroy that 60 40 split
very very soon and last but not least
anybody in a position and working for a
good company may be offered some bonuses
that add to the streams of income that's
all for me today guys they are my 12
streams of income to decide you'll find
more great architectural content down
below you'll find the Subscribe button
and feel free to leave any comments down
below like I said that is it for me so
like always I'll see you next Monday